лінія фронту під бахмутом українські
військові тут надійно окопалися США та
інші партнери радили Україні відступити
з міста кажучи що ціна занадто висока
однак Україна продовжує оберняти Бахмут
І судячи з усього готується до великого
весняного контрнаменту
це буде очікуємо коли невідомо ми всі в
очікуванні цікаво коли це станеться
будемо виїжджати відпрацьовувати
всі конечно ждем тут техніку тому що
дуже бистро ждем щось нове партнерів
наших заграничних
починаючи з травня українці мали
перевагу на своєму боці вони задають
темп війни і як ми бачили було три
великі виведення російських військ з
території які вони раніше утримували На
даний момент є три фронти це Крим Бахмут
та Запорізький Якщо коротко То в Криму
українці досягли невеликих успіхів за
останні кілька тижнів у бахмуті росіяни
досягли невеликих успіхів ціною жахливих
втрат А на півдні Запоріжжі поки великий
знак питання тому що це найбільш
очевидне місце для українського наступу
в 2023 році тому обидві сторони
зміцнюються там І вичікують що зробить
інше
західні військові аналітики сходяться на
тому що одним із ймовірних напрямків
контернаступу України є Запорізький з
метою відвоювати Мелітополь і тим самим
перерізати сухопутну лінію постачання
російської армії до Криму
Я вважаю що бої навколо бахмута далися
Дорогою ціною але вони також були
необхідними генеральний штаб бачив що
вони можуть зупинити російські війська в
бахмуті знекровити їх і змусити їх
використати багато ресурсів не вводячи
власні Українські бронетанкові сили до
бахмута це те що їм знадобиться коли
вони справді почнуть власник Контрнаступ
який На мою думку відбуватиметься на
дуже вузькому фронті щоб досягти
вирішального ефекту аби зруйнувати
сухопутний міст між Кримом і рештою
Росії
саме відвоювання Криму як вважає екс
командувач армії США у Європі Бен ходжес
може змінити стратегічну обстановку на
фронті
Крим вирішальний терен ви можете вбити
кожного російського солдата в радіусі
200 км від бахмута але це не змінить
стратегічну обстановку але якщо ви
звільнете Крим це все змінює тому
Контрнаступ буде спрямований на
звільнення Криму а потім і решти Донбасу
що як я думаю буде пізніше
український військовий аналітик Юрій
Бутусов також звертає увагу на
важливість бахмута для імовірного
контрнаступу стосовно бахмута
втримання бахмута в таких умовах
тактичній обстановці яка є зараз
має свою логіку у двох випадках або якщо
зараз
в тилу створюється потужна лінія оборони
ефективна
і тоді ми виграємо час для того щоб
потім закріпитися на відступати
або готуються контрудари Можливо на
якихось інших напрямках Можливо на цьому
напрямку ми не знаємо де але
Сподіваємось що
такі важкі бої в такі обстановці яка є
зараз коли ворог глибоко охопив місто з
флангів коли глибоко просунувся в
забудову
що вищою командування є своя логіка дій
у свій задум який зараз реалізовується
те щоб розпочати будь-який Контрнаступ
потрібна зброя і боєприпаси в Україну
вже прибула частина західних танків
зокрема британський челенджери та
німецький леопарди 2 А ось США пообіцяли
передати далекобійні ракети скерованими
боєприпасами gls db
американсько-шведського виробництва ці
розумні авіабомби випущені з хаймерсів
мають дальність дії 150 км що майже
вдвічі більше ніж у тих ракет які нині
використовує Україна внаслідок цього під
приціли українських військових потрапило
б набагато більше російських цілей
включно зі складами боєприпасів
ви пам'ятаєте коли Хай марсив вперше
прибули на поле бою минулого літа І
відразу ж почали вражати російські
склади боєприпасів російських штаб і
тому росіяни вийшли за межі 90
кілометрів яких могли досягати ці ракети
Отже якщо Україна фактично отримує бомби
наземного базування малого діаметру з
радіусом дії 150 км Це означає що
збільшиться кількість російських штабів
артилерійських сховищ і транспортних
мереж які опиняться у зоні досяжності
але поки що українські військові на
передовій відчувають хронічну нестачу
боєприпасів для вже наявної техніки
тижня два назад Тут стріляли повністю
весь свій боєкомплект і в нас не було
чим стріляти чотири дня ми були без
роботи то есть зарядний голод склалося
на всіх Нам потрібні снаряди а готують
вообще Контрнаступ чим прикривати піходу
палками кидатися по ним чи що
зламану техніку радянської доби тут на
фронті доводиться ремонтувати щоденно
машина просто була як швейцарський сир
Хоча вона і працювала ну
задня частина була все повністю по
металу потім вже і АвтоТак накрили що
воно вже не вивезла просто осталася в
неї одна рама підтікання мастила або
двигуна або трансмісії ну це саме
найчастіше проблема лопається патрубки
течуть тільки-то прокладки ну трохи вік
трохи такі умови експлуатації достаточно
жорстке що вони постоянно їздять
постоянно стріляти водночас за словами
військового експерта Юрія Бутусова
наявність великої кількості західної
зброї ще не означає готовності до
контрнаступу ми удали насправді дуже
велику кількість зброї Ми отримали вже
багато сотень західних бойових машин
виробництва НАТО
і треба розуміти що
в західні бойові машини диктують нову
тактику застосування
тому в сучасній війні Важливо не просто
навчитися правильні кнопки і важелі
натискати в машині щоб вона їхала або
стріляла
а потрібно передусім мислення
усвідомлення і сильних сторін цієї
бойової техніки і застосування
планування їх на полі бою водночас Юрій
ботусав поки не бачить передумов
повторити блискучі контрнаступальні
успіхи ЗСУ як це було восени на
Харківщині та Херсонщині за його словами
тоді були зовсім інші обставини а
противник був виснажений і де
зорганізований що призвело до розвалу
оборони росіян що зараз
ворог має велику щільність військ
побудував тилову позицію він зробив
висновки по всій лінії фронту відриті
тилові позиції потужні
Розгорнуті резервні частини да Можливо
вони не зовсім боєздатні не настільки
боєздатні але вони є вони можуть діяти
це велика кількість людей велика
кількість техніки
і тому зараз у такій проїзд
які перетворюються в прорив він
неможливий бо тоді були створені умови А
зараз немає також визнає що за зиму
росіяни мали час провести роботу над
помилками та укріпитися на тих позиціях
які вони загарбали але цей час з користю
використали також ЗСУ тому Він чекає від
української сторони нових несподіваних
атак
росіяни не дурні Вони знають що
контранаступ наближається тому
намагатимуться цьому якось запобігти
Очевидно вони доклали багато зусиль аби
окупатися у траншеях та розставити різні
перешкоди Але я думаю що українці
виберуть правильний час і місце коли
погода прохідність доріг усі умови
будуть створені щоб вони могли доставити
більше високоточної зброї великої
дальності яка допоможе зробити досяжним
Кримський півострів
атака на штаби місця зберігання
боєприпасів так можна знищити масу Так
вони і реалі єте перевагу єдину перевагу
яка є у росіян
добре звалити оборону противника треба
більшу кількість снарядів більшу
кількість штурмових підрозділів
бронетехніки розвідувальних засобів та
засобів керування зауважує Бутусов На
його думку головне нині забезпечити
насамперед тактичну перевагу на фронті
щоб темп втрат противника перевищував
його мобілізаційні можливості
у війні на виснаження основний
основний фактор
переваги який створює
можливості в тому числі для звільнення
території це
зниження боєздатності російських військ
Тобто нам потрібно підірвати їхню
боєздатність
щоб ворог був виснажений було виснажені
його
фронтові частини виснажені його
оперативні резерви і саме це створює
сприятливі можливості для атакувальних
дій для наступу наступ без підготовки
неможливий успішний наступ починається
зі створення умов для наступу так от
зараз іде боротьба за умови за
ініціативу без цієї боротьби боротьби
якщо ми не виграємо боротьбу за
ініціативу
наступу не буде тоді коли це буде
безумовно будуть умови для наступу зараз
поки що говорити про наступ це
надихати себе оптимізмом тим часом
тисячі українських військових вже
успішно прийшли навчання з опанування
сучасної західної військової техніки
крім того за інформацією його агентства
ройтерс збройні сили України готують 8
нових штурмових бригад загальної
чисельністю 40 тисяч осіб це мотивовані
добровольці які прийшли у військо в
рамках компанії під назвою Гвардія
наступу яку запустило Міністерство
внутрішніх справ України на початку
лютого їх планують задіяти У майбутньому
можливому
контрнаступів я хочу щоб війна
закінчилася якомога швидше і я
сподіваюся що штурмова бригада зробить
Це набагато швидше я хочу бути
ефективнішим тому я її вибрав
за своєю Я перейшов Тому що тут
підготовка вставлення хороші умови
багато чого навчають Ну і щоб швидше
поїхати на Схід багато втратив друзів
Там і хочу помститися це реально
можливість
дати відпір цій навалі це штурмові
бригади А хто як не штурмовики ідуть
вперед Ну і хочеться таким чином
себе реалізувати Я прагну тієї як це
правильно сказати помсти як би це не
було жорстко в 21 столітті але Помста за
наших людей за тих діток заборгованих
мусимо Хто як не ми для Києва Багато
залежить від контернаступу зазначають
західні аналітики невдала спроба
повернути захоплені Росією територією
може послабити оптимізм ключових
західних партнерів України та змусити їх
підштовхувати Київ до переговорів із
Москвою